ja wir kommen zur heutigen sitzung in
der wir uns nochmal mit absender und
thomas von aquin befassen werden und
dann auf leibnitz hier eingehen werden
der im zentrum der sitzung auch stehen
sollen
die letzte sitzung war recht dicht
gepackt knallharte metaphysik des
mittelalters verschiedene
unterscheidungen bezüglich des seins
begriffs analoge uni wo kate walker
science begriff und das möchte ich noch
mal ganz kurz heute erklären und dann
möchte ich auch noch ein bisschen auf
lena und thomas von aquin eingehen die
versteht man selten gleich beim ersten
mal so dann gehen wir doch einfach mal
hier nochmal ein bisschen zurück also
zusammenfassung der letzten sitzung
diese beiden netten herren hier also ab
wie senna war ein persisch sprechen der
philosoph der übrigens auch einen sehr
interessanten kanon der medizin
geschrieben hat und also ein wirkliches
kompendium an mit an medizin
medizinischen praktiken gegenüber allen
möglichen erkrankungen wie zum beispiel
fieber usw also sehr interessanter denke
wir haben uns folgende fragen gestellt
wie vor bestimme navi senna und thomas
winter sein
sie verhalten sich ihre ontologien als
ihre lehren von dem sein denn zu
denjenigen bei platon und aristoteles
wie vielen trend thomas von aquin das
wsn die essenz von der existenz der
essential das waren sie die drei fragen
und jetzt müssen wir hier drei science
begriffe auseinander halten nämlich zum
einen den uni wogen science begriff den
analogen science begriff und den equipen
science begriff will ich noch einmal
ganz kurz erklären hat mir in der
letzten sitzung eigentlich schon
ausführlich gemacht wie auch immer ein
beispiel geben
universals begriff sagt das wort sein
oder existenz wird mit blick auf alle
dinge auf die zählweise verwende
alle dinge existieren auf dieselbe weise
sind auf dieselbe weise seien seine
existenz ist das allgemein sste merkmal
aller dinge wenn wir von allen
eigenschaften der dinge ihrer essenz
absinth bleibt existenz übrig und hier
ist ein vertreter den ich noch nach nach
liefere der duns scotus das ist ein
mittelalterlicher denkers coaches können
sie schon sehen der hat in schottland
geliebt der hat als er gesagt wir reden
mit blick auf alles was existiert mit
derselben hinsicht in derselben hinsicht
von seiner existenz und nicht jetzt im
stärkeren oder schwächeren maße oder nur
in einer logischen hinsicht das ist so
eine seltene position aber sie gibt dann
haben wir eine quote science begriff da
liefert ihnen auch noch einen vertreter
nach den hatte ich das letzte mal nicht
genannt das bedeutet das wort sein
existieren wird mit blick auf alle dinge
auf ganz verschiedene weise befindet
also betonung hier auf ganz verschieden
vielleicht sollte ich auch noch besser
sagen auf völlig verschiedene weise das
wort sein klingt nur gleich in beiden
male also zb bank oder bank oder stollen
und stollen als sie können einen stollen
in den berg hinein treiben sie können
einen stollen essen es gibt fußball
schuhe die haben stollen dran
das mag zwar irgendwie gemeinsamkeit
geben aber eigentlich haben sie nichts
miteinander zu tun völlig diese wörter
obwohl sie gleich klingen bezeichnen
ganz verschiedenes und so ist es auch
mit blick auf den science begriffe
gemeint ich darf an dieses spiel
teekesselchen erinnern also alle dinge
existieren auf verschiedene weise sind
auf verschiedene weise sein also ganz
verschieden so wie eben stollen am schuh
nichts mit dem stollen zu tun hat den
mann ist so müssen sich das vorstellen
das problem ist jetzt dass das eben der
begriff des seins viel unklarer ist als
der begriff des stollens und seinen
verschiedenen bedeutung und das wort
steuern
also sein ist ziemlich vage das ist sehr
fließt dann eigentlich der begriff
zerfließt einem zwischen den händen
und deswegen ist es auch schwierig hier
von egg wie vogue zu sprechen
aber es gibt einen vertretern der
philosophiegeschichte nämlich der neue
platonischer portfolios so im dritten
jahrhundert hat er gelebt und der hat
diese these vertreten dass wir also wenn
wir sagen sein dass in völlig
verschiedener hinsicht gebrauchen können
also das ist eigentlich gar nichts
miteinander zu tun hat dass es nur das
bloße ford ist den liefere ich jetzt ihn
also hiermit noch nach den neue
platonischer neue blatt ohne gemeint
also ein denker eine denkerin die eben
die thesen von platon radikalisiert oder
eben modifiziert hat das ist sehr
interessante geistesgeschichtliche
entwicklungen hier spricht spielt
darüber der blick begriff des einen eine
große rolle also kann ich auch schon mal
vorausgreifend sagen es gibt die so
genannten transzendentalen im
mittelalter um das eine wehr um das
wahre bonn um das gute sind nur einige
davon
und diese trends and a liehen die
betreffe neben die letzten
grundstrukturen all dessen was ist und
dieses um dieses eine
das ist für die neue platonischer
besonders wichtig also existenz und
einheit werden hier sehr eng zusammen
gedacht
ja und dann gibt es noch zu guter letzt
in analogen science begriff der wird am
häufigsten verwendet bedeutet so fiel
das wort sein existieren wird mit blick
auf alle dinge auf verwandte weise
verwendet oder auf analoge weise
verwendet alle dinge existieren auf
verschiedene weise wenn auch nicht auf
gänzlich verschiedene weise gänzlich
verschiedener hinsicht dass wir nämlich
dann die woge sein zugriff die dinge
sind auch verschiedene weise oder auch
in verschiedenem gerade sein und hier
gibt es als vertreter eben platon und
aristoteles die vertretenen analogen
science begriff wenn auch natürlich noch
ein bisschen anderen sinne und da möchte
ich jetzt eben noch mal ein bisschen
genauer darauf ein
dass wir uns mal dem aristoteles widmen
und seinem analogen science begriff auch
thomas von aquin vertritt tendenziell
analogen science begriff auch wenn ich
jetzt mal gesagt hatte dass es auch eine
tendenz des uni wogen bei ihm gibt aber
niveau wie gesagt eher duns scotus
vielleicht können wir von dem auch noch
was lesen dass so das ist also der nette
herr das ist der aristoteles im vierten
jahrhundert vor christus und der sagt
jetzt folgendes das möchte ich jetzt
noch nachliefern
das seien de wird in mehrfacher
bedeutung gebraucht also man könnte auch
sagen das wort seien aber immer in
beziehung auf eines griechisch heißt es
post zu hin und her ist es eins und auf
eine einzige wesenheit und nicht nach
bloßer namensgleichheit das wäre der
äquivalenz mitteln sollen wie alles und
jetzt gibt ein beispiel was gesund
genannt wird sich auf gesundheit bezieht
in dem es die selbe gesundheit nämlich
hält oder hervorbringt oder ein zeichen
derselben oder sie aufzunehmen fake ist
wie etwas ärztlich heißt in beziehung
auf die arznei kunde entweder weil es
die arznei kunde besitzt oder zu ihr
wohl befähigt und ein berg derselben ist
und wie wir dasselbe beim gebrauchte
übrigen wörter finden werden
ebenso wird auch der seite 2 und
vielfachen bedeutungen ausgesagt aber
doch alles in beziehung oder auch analog
auf ein prinzip hat das ist so ein
gesang der analoge science begriff wir
verwenden seinen verschiedenen bedeutung
aber nicht so verschieden
das ist wie vogue wäre sondern wenn wir
zum beispiel jetzt hier das beispiel um
gesundheit nehmen dann kann
verschiedenes gesund genannt werden
jetzt kann zum beispiel ein mensch
gesund sein der einfach nicht krank ist
es kann aber auch ein nahrungsmittel
gesund sein weil es gesundheit befördert
und so kann man sich nach aristoteles
eben auch das wörtchen zahlen in seiner
verwendung vorstellen es meint
eigentlich so ungefähr dasselbe aber
eben nicht
ganz genau aber es ist nicht so
verschieden gebraucht dass es ganz
unterschiedliches betrifft ist die
analoge science begriff weiteres zitat
von ihm denn einiges wird als sein
bezeichnet weil es wesenheit das ist die
substanz anders weil es auf aktion der
wesenheit zum beispiel qualität oder ein
akzidenz anderes weil es der weg zur
wesenheit oder untergang oder beraubung
unter qualität
naja das ist eigentlich das ohne dass
schaffende und erzeugen die ist für die
wesenheit dass die substanz oder für
etwas in beziehung zu derselben
stehendes oder negation von etwas unter
diesen oder von der wesenheit deshalb
sagen wir ja auch das nicht sein das sei
nicht sein
wie nun alles gesunde einer wissenschaft
angehört so verhält es sich gleicher
weise auch bei den übrigen denn nicht
nur die untersuchung dessen was nach
einem bestimmt oder einem untergeordnet
ist sind auch dessen was in beziehung
auf 1 ausgesagt wird ist gegenstand
einer einzigen wissenschaft in gewissem
sinne ist auch dies nach einem
bestimmten computer das beispiel mit der
gesundheit ein spiel also das sind jetzt
natürlich das wissen sie sofort da sind
die zehn kategorien auf die iran spielt
ja und diese hauptkategorie das sein
dann ist die substanz weil es in dem
sprachlichen syntaktischen satzbau die
subjekt stelle betrifft nach der wir
immer fragen wer oder was ist oder tod
usw
das objekt von dem dann alles gibt ihm
was produziert wird also das pferd steht
auf der weide und so weiter und so fort
wir müssen immer wissen wer oder was ist
gemeint und das ist die erste die
hauptsächlich sste bedeutung haben wir
können eben auch noch andere sinne von
seien unterscheiden wir können sagen wie
viel ist es wie ist es wie ist
ästhetisch wie ist es wirkend usw
also wir können seien nicht als oberste
gattung verwenden
das ist das nächste zitat
es ist auch ganz wichtig dass sein sagt
aristoteles in seiner zweiten analytik
ist aber für kein ding wesenheit denn
das sein der ist nicht gattung
das ist ein ganz wichtiges zitat das
seiende oder das sein ist nicht eine
gattung das griechisch hier ist genoss
also übersetzt wörtlich heißt nicht
nämlich ist nicht nämlich dass die
gattung dass sein und sie müssen sich
ergänzen ist als denn die gattung ist
nicht das sein wird ist also nicht so
dass es jetzt aristoteles glaubt es gibt
ja so eine gattung wie es zb irgendwie
lebewesen gibt und dann gibt es da eben
verschiedene arten darunter so darf man
sich nach aristoteles design nicht
vorstellen also dass seine oder sein ist
nicht die höchste gattung hat
verschiedene argumente dafür das wird
jetzt so weit führen die zu diskutieren
ist nicht ganz leicht
er sagte ebenso kann man nicht vom sein
reden dass es die höchste gattung ist es
sein wir können vom seien immer nur
analog sprechen in verschiedenen
hinsichten und da gelten dann die
kategorien vor allem eben die substanz
die usa
das ist auch nur ein wichtiges zitat so
jetzt wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen
kurz hier auf den arena eingehen ich
hatte schon ein bischen was erzähle hat
einen interessanten kanon der medizin
geschrieben sehr interessante person
lohnt sich wirklich die auch mal ein
bisschen näher zu betrachten
ich werde ein paar weitere texte und
quellen von ihm auch ins internet
stellen ins moodle system bitte melden
sie sich noch an falls ich es nicht
gemacht haben und auch im sap system
können sie ein bisschen weiter lesen so
und der sagt folgendes die sind ein
neues zitat um jetzt überlegen sie sich
mal bei diesem zitat an wen sie das
erinnert den wir schon intensiver
behandelt hatten
er sagt folgendes wenn auch die existenz
kein genuss keine gattung ist noch von
dem was in ihrem umfeld in gleicher
weise und die vocal anonymus ausgesagt
wird so ist sie dennoch ein begriff
in dem die dinge nach dem früher oder
später übereinstimmen in erster linie
wird er den begriff von der wesenheit
alles gesagt die die substanz ist in
zweiter linie von den dingen die auf die
substanz folgen die neuen aktien ziehen
weil nun dieser begriff ein einziger ist
in dem sinne wie wir es früher
andeuteten zu haften ihm akzidenzen an
die e-mail eigentümliche weise zu kommen
wie wir es ebenfalls früher erklärt
haben und daher erstreckt sich auf ihn
nur eine einzige wissenschaft wie auch
für alles was die gesundheit angeht nur
eine wissenschaft die medizin besteht
dass aus seiner schrift über die
metaphysischen dinge ja ganz klar das
haben sie natürlich sofort gemerkt er
bezieht sich hier auf aristoteles es ist
eigentlich jetzt endlich ein aristoteles
kommentare den er hier betreibt auch
wenn er immer mal wieder eigene gedanken
einfließen lässt also diese
frühmittelalterlichen denker auch im
arabischen bereich die hatten sich sehr
an aristoteles orientiert und platin
wurde erst später wieder in der
renaissance dann entdeckt der war lange
zeit einfach nicht bekannt ganz
erstaunlich im mittelalter nur dann über
die neue platonischer ja alles total es
war die haupt bezugsquelle so ein
weiteres zitat das ding und das was
gleichbedeutend ist bedeutet in allen
sprachen manchmal etwas anderes denn
jedes ding hat eine reale wesenheit
durch die das ding das ist was es ist
das dreieck hat daher ein reales wesen
das entry angenommen dass drei weg sein
und ebenso die weiße farbe das esse
album dass das weiß sein als
artbestimmung dieses bezeichnen wir
häufig als das partikuläre sein ohne
dass dadurch der begriff des
existierenden bezeichnet wird
denn der ausdruck existenz bedeutet noch
viele andere begriffe zum beispiel das
reale wesen das sind inhalt des dinges
ausmacht demzufolge ist dasjenige was
den inhalt des dinges ausmacht seine
essenziell dass partikuläre sein
das ding ist also hier sagt er jetzt
[Musik]
das reale wesen bezeichnen wir als
partikuläre sein ohne dass wir damit
auch die existenz bezeichnen also hier
scheint mir schon so eine gewisse
differenz aufzutreten nämlich zwischen
der essenz der wesenheit und der
existenz das ist ja ein thema was wir
auch noch bei thomas von aquin genauer
10 wer hat noch einge zitat es ist klar
dass jedes ding eine partikuläre essenz
ja also wesenheit besitzt nämlich sein
wesen ist es zugleich bekannt dass die
essenziell jedes ding ist ihm in
besonderer weise zukunft verschieden ist
von dem sein
der grund dafür ist folgende wenn du
sagst das wesen dieses gegenstandes hat
wirklich existenz entweder in den
individuellen dingen oder im geiste
absolut genommen indem letzterer begriff
die beiden ersten umschließt so bedeutet
diese aussage etwas bestimmtes und
begrifflich fassbares also das ist das
der punkt das wesen dieses gegenstandes
hat wirkliche existenz das heißt ja und
hier sieht man diese unterscheidung
zwischen einem wesen war es auch nicht
wirklich existenz haben muss also dass
etwas anwesen hat heißt nicht dass es
existiert hier ist wieder diese
differenz zwischen essentiell und
existenz ja und jetzt kommen wir zu
diesen netten herren hier das ist der
thomas von aquin und er hat ein ganz
interessantes buch geschrieben und ich
darf ihnen jetzt in kleinen tipp geben
wie das anfängt also die ente oder
genauer gesagt die antisense ja über das
seine und das wesen und er sagte er
folgendes es ist unmöglich dass es eine
materie ohne eine form gibt doch ist es
nicht unmöglich dass es eine form ohne
materie gebe die form nämlich sofern sie
form ist hat keine abhängigkeit von der
materie
also die form ist hier das entscheidende
die materie kann nicht in form
existieren aber die form ohne materie
das ist eine anknüpfung an aristoteles
in seinen sogenannten home office muss
hülle ist der stoff und nur veh ist die
form und nach aristoteles muss immer
stoffen form zusammen kommen aber nicht
jetzt irgendwie additiv also im sinne
von zwei gegenstimmen die wir zu
verschmelzen
sind sie ihr so logische momente einer
sache oder aspekte und theologische
aspekte die wir an jedem existieren
wesen in abhebung bringen können jetzt
kann man sich natürlich fragen wie hängt
form mit existenz und essen zusammen
die form bedarf nämlich wie gesagt nicht
ihrer ganzen gattung nachdem materie
formen solche art die ohne materie
bestehen die vernunft gewesen
intelligenzen daher müssen die
wesenheiten oder weisheiten dieser
substanzen nichts anderes seien als
selbst form also ist es möglich dass es
eben vernunft gewesen gibt die allein in
der form bestehen
aristoteles war da ein bisschen
zurückhaltender
der hatte also eigentlich gemeint die
form existiert selten oder eigentlich
gar nicht unabhängig von der materie hat
also die form hat auch immer eine
ähnlichkeit zu idee wären platon wie sie
jetzt mittlerweile wissen sehr geneigt
war oder eigentlich seine grundthese
darin bestand dass die wesenheit oder
die form oder die idee dass verwendet er
häufig synonym dass die eben gerade
unabhängig von der materie bestimmt
besteht und dass die also die
materiellen dinge dass die letztendlich
anteil haben an diesen ideen
das ist das sogenannte linie gleichnis
und dann gibt es diese weiteren gleichen
diese sonnen gleichnis und höhengleichen
sich nach oben rechts dann nachher im
youtube video den link zu dieser
entsprechenden stelle rein dann kommt
jetzt eben noch ein wichtiges zitat die
wesenheit des einfachen dinge es
hingegen die dessen form ist kann nur
als ganzes betrachtet werden da ist hier
außer der form nichts anderes
was gleichsam die form aufnehmen wie
auch immer man daher die wesenheit der
einfachen substanz annehmen mag sie wird
doch von dieser als ganze ausgesagt der
deshalb sagt avi sinne dass die weisheit
und einfaches der einfachen substanz
selbst etwas einfaches ist weil es
nichts anderes gibt was sie auf hier
gibt es in bezug zur wiesn substanzen
sagte weiter diese art sind also nur
formen ohne materie gleichwohl zeigt
sich in ihnen nicht in jeder hinsicht
einfachheit dass sie reine aktivieren
sondern sie haben eine beimischung von
potenz möglichkeit das ist auch ein
wichtiger begriff potenzial die
möglichkeit und die wirklichkeit die
fans ja und dies wird aus folgen
offenbar war es nämlich nicht zum
begriff der wesenheit oder wahrheit
gehört das kommt zu ihr von außen hinzu
und bild mit der wesenheit eine
zusammensetzung das als akzeptieren man
kann nämlich keine wesenheit ohne das
was ihre teile sind einsehen jede
wesenheit oder wahrheit kann aber
eingesehen werden ohne dass man etwas
von ihrem sein ein sieht wenn denn ich
kann zum beispiel ein sehen was der
mensch oder der phoenix ist und doch
nicht wissen ob er ein seien in der
natur der dinge hat also leuchtet ein
dass das seien verschieden ist von der
wesenheit oder war's halt das ist jetzt
also ganz ganz zentral dieses letzte hat
dass das sei man könnte auch sagen dass
meine existenz dass die verschieden ist
von der wesenheit oder von der wahrheit
das beispiel war ich kann eben ein sehen
war es ein bestimmter mensch oder was
der mensch grundsätzlich ist ohne dass
er dadurch existieren muss der mensch
genauso phoenix dieses farbe wesen
phönix aus der asche kann ich auch
verstehen was damit gemeint ist die
bedeutung dieses wortes kann ich
verstehen dass wäre die essenz aber
damit geht noch nicht einher dass es
auch wirklich existiert ja das ist schon
ein kleiner vor blick hierauf leibnitz
und seine
analytische bestimmung von existenz gibt
jetzt noch ein tag bei thomas von aquin
das zeigt jetzt eben dass er die ganze
thematik an theologischen perspektive
auch betrachtet außer wenn es vielleicht
ein ding gibt sagte dessen weisheit
dessen es zensierter seien die existenz
ja selbst ist und dieses kann nur eines
und ein erstes sein denn unmöglich kann
eine vervielfältigung von etwas
stattfinden
außer entweder durch hinzufügung eines
unterschiedlich auf diese weise
vervielfältigt sich die natur die
gattung in die arten oder durch die
aufnahme der form in verschiedene
materien und auf diese weise
vervielfältigt sich die natur derart in
verschiedenen individuen oder dadurch
dass eines ein prinzip absolut ist und
anders etwas aufgenommen wird
aber jetzt gar nicht weiter lesen er
sagt jetzt hier nur also normalerweise
bei mensch bei phoenix müssen wir
existenz und essence unterscheiden
aber es könnte eine ausnahme geben eben
ein ding dessen wahrheit dass sein
selbst ist und das ist natürlich gottes
gott damit gemeint für den eben diese
unterscheidung dieses auseinanderfallen
von essens- und existenz dieses mit
diese logische unterscheidung die thomas
von aquin für alles weltlich
existierende annimmt nicht gilt
ja das ist das vielleicht noch ein zitat
das kann eigentlich auch überspringen
das ist eben die zentrale these von
thomas von aquin und wir werden uns
jetzt gleich mit diesem denken
beschäftigen mit gottfried wilhelm
leibniz die sehen anhand seiner
lebensdaten er hat im vor allem im 17
jahrhundert gelebt das ist die zeit
kulturgeschichtlich des barock das ist
philosophie geschichtlich die zeit des
rationalismus im gegensatz auch zum
impuls muss der auch existierte zu
dieser zeit also rationalismus bedeutet
die frage nach erkenntnis nach seien die
wird immer mit bezug auf vernünftige
logische prinzipien geklärt während der
empirismus des tc vertrag dass die frage
nach dem
es existiert und was wir erkennen können
immer mit rekurs auf unsere erfahrung
als empirisch bestimmt werden kann also
leibnitz ist ein ganz ganz rationaler
philosoph und jetzt wollen wir uns
gleich damit der frage befassen wie er
existenz und essenz aus logischer
hinsicht denkt logischer hinsicht denkt